providence island
holds the promise of a past yet to be
discovered 200 years ago freed american
slaves settled here and founded liberia
we visited the island in october 2021.
look at it now
the island appears to be shrinking with
the rising tide a window into the past
is disappearing says young liberian
archaeologist foote it's very painful
because this connects our histories the
area is on a threat in that in the next
few years
the water will cover the entire place
thereby erasing the entire historical
site of the republic
in the summer liberian and american
archaeologists excavated parts of the
island they found ceramics from ships
from the caribbean the americas and
europe but also further afield their
findings brought more questions than
answers on the other side of the
atlantic american archaeologist matt
reilly says it isn't just parts of
liberian history but american history as
well being lost to the rising water just
about a meter below the surface we were
encountering the water table artifacts
that were already being absorbed into
the riverbed system and as the water
table continues to rise these
archaeological deposits are at risk of
being destroyed losing the
archaeological integrity of these very
significant sites before we even have a
chance to study them and that goes for
many of those significant heritage sites
across the coastal region all 19th
century sites that were settled by free
african americans which represent an
unparalleled type of story in the
history of the african diaspora
almost 800 000 people across west africa
are displaced because of ongoing
torrential rains and floods monrovia is
barely a meter above sea level with a
rising ocean the slums are sinking and
so are the historical sites
on providence island archaeologists
found the remains of vessels artifacts
and settlements but look at it now
it is for them a race against the tide
to dig and retrieve what they can
because an important chapter of human
history is disappearing as we speak
for young archaeologist foote there is a
sinking feeling of grief
to a land lost
to seeing his roots his identity
vanish in the water
nicholas hawk al jazeera providence
island liberia